okay six one seven eight three zero 4750
why don't we next try our caller from
the 302 area code caller from 302 tell
us who you are tell me what's on your
mind today
hi my name is Venus Lin and I was
calling about that a plant kratom that
the government's trying to ban yeah have
you have you called before about that
yeah yeah I just with it what's new with
it we're trying to get all the
representatives to sign the Dear
Colleague letters from to cut the pecans
though beyond their Dear Colleague
letter to get them to research the
entire science the entire science the
entire kratom body of science I'm sorry
so they don't keep it legal they're
trying to say that the deaths that had
they had kratom in their system they
were actually caught they had a lot of
other things nurses don't write a time
for the legalization of kratom but just
to not rehash our last phone call I'm
genuinely curious how much of your time
is spent on kratom related stuff like
just as an innocent quite I'm just
curious like are you a full-time kratom
activist well I was really sick for 17
years so I'm going there so this is
about all I can do right now is make
phone calls and eventually yes that is
what I would like to do because I just
want to help people and kratom will
state lies
ya know we've done an interview on
kratom and I think that there's very
very interesting potential there I wish
I knew more about it I know some and of
course we did research for that
interview but I think it's a very very
interesting thing thank you for the call
very much appreciate keep up the keep up
the activism on kratom